straw input is a useful practice that
can improve soil fertility and crop
yields while simultaneously helping to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
however if not done properly it can lead
to excessive emissions of greenhouse
gases such as CO2 CH4 and n2o
a recent study has shown that the
optimal combination of straw input and
management practices can help to reduce
these emissions while still providing
benefits to Farmers
this includes low straw input rates
straw mulching application of straw with
a high c n ratio long-term straw input
and no tillage combined with straw input
these measures have been found to be
effective at reducing greenhouse gas
emissions without sacrificing crop yield
or soil quality
this article was authored by pinkfaily
afing Zhang Choi Huang and others